>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> In 2001, I witnessed
a distinguished panel
of judges discuss the
mastery of an excerpt
from Jonathan Franzen's
novel, The Corrections,
and recommend its author for an NEA
Fellowship not knowing or taking
into consideration
who the author was.
Five years later, I had the
pleasure of working with Jonathan
when he served as a judge
for the NEA Fellowships.
So I can tell you a
little bit about him.
His descriptions of Washington,
D.C. notwithstanding, he is smart,
observant, and obviously
dedicated to his craft.
I might also say he is nice but
having finished his latest novel,
Freedom, I am too afraid to
ever use that word again.
So I'm thinking at this point that
you folks already know all that.
I'm thinking here is a
man who doesn't need much
of an introduction these days.
You probably saw him on the cover
of Time Magazine, the first author
to appear there in a decade.
I'm guessing you also read at
least one of the rhapsodic reviews
of Freedom which, by now,
could probably fill more
pages than the book itself.
Maybe you read that President
Obama read Freedom on his vacation
or that Oprah let bygones
be bygones and chose Freedom
as her first book group
pick in over a year.
Maybe you are a fan of
Jonathan from years ago
when The Corrections won
the National Book Award
and was shortlisted
for the Pulitzer Prize
and the National Book Critics Circle
award and the PEN/Faulkner Award.
Maybe you continued to read his
work, his collections of essays.
His collection of essays,
How to be Alone
or his memoirs, The Discomfort Zone.
Maybe you've read his pieces
in The New Yorker or Harper's
and have opinions on his take on
the contemporary literary landscape
or other's take on his take of the
literary landscape or other's take
on how the landscape favors men
or postmodernism or I don't know,
roaming house cats, not
a shy group we novelists.
Maybe you saw Jonathan on The
Simpsons and you're hoping like I am
that his career trajectory with
all its excesses of fame leads him
to a special Christmas album
or doing the cha-cha-cha
and dances with the stars.
[ Laughter ]
>> We can dream.
Or maybe you don't know Jonathan
and you're just now learning
about Freedom, this new tour
de force that he's written.
Well then, let me warn you.
In the words of one character,
Freedom is a pain in the ass.
The book unleashes a bizarre
pathological sequence of events
that befalls Americans like you
and me and will make you unhappy.
But as the narrator tells us,
there is a kind of happiness
in unhappiness if it's
the right unhappiness.
We owe a great deal of
thanks to Jonathan Franzen
for giving literature
back its shining moment
for writing a big ambitious literary
novel that has grabbed headlines
and makes us think
and feel and opine
and reflect all while we're
pondering what it means
to have the freedom to do so.
We owe him thanks for giving us
the right kind of unhappiness.
Please join me in welcoming
Jonathan Franzen.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Sorry, I almost took the bottle
with Jane Smiley's name on it.
[ Laughter ]
>> They actually have
the water bottles labeled
with the writer's names.
So it's nice to be here.
I'm told I'm not allowed to
read to you from the book.
I'm speaking at a normal
tone of voice.
I can't really do it much louder,
perhaps if that throbbing
generator sort of noise would stop.
Anyway, I was asked to say
something about my process.
And just by good fortune, I have a
manuscript in my briefcase suitable
for perhaps 15 minutes of discussion
of that, at which point I'll turn it
over to questions and answers.
Thank you all for coming out here.
It's not as hot as it could be.
[ Laughter ]
[ Pause ]
>> I gave the whole text
of the speech at Seattle
but it lasted about 40 minutes.
So if I suddenly start speaking
of you all here in Seattle,
it's because I haven't had
time to revise the manuscript.
Okay, it seems to me something of
a miracle that people still come
out to hear a writer speak
instead of staying home
with their televisions
and computers.
I'd spent a lot of time in the
last few years sitting alone
in a darkened room, and so
it's great to come here and see
so many people who care about books.
I'm gonna begin this talk by
addressing four unwelcomed questions
that novelists are often asked
in a course of an evening
like this, morning, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>> I thought I have reached the
last evening but there was one more.
These questions are apparently
the price we have to pay
for the pleasure of
appearing in public.
They are vexing and maddening
not just because we're asked them
so often but also because with
one exception they are difficult
to answer and therefore
very much worth asking.
The first of these
perennial questions is
who are your influences?
Sometimes the person asking this
question merely wants some book
recommendations but all too
often, the question seems
to be intended seriously.
And part of what's annoying
about the question is
that it's always asked
in the present tense,
who are my influences.
At this point in my life, I'm mostly
influenced by my own past writing.
If I were still walking in the
shadow of say E.M. Forster,
I would certainly be at
pains to pretend I wasn't.
According to Mr. Harold Bloom
whose very clever theory
of literary influence
helped him make a career
of being a cannon maker, I wouldn't
even be conscious to the degree
to which I was still laboring
an E.M. Forster shadow.
Only Harold Bloom would be
fully conscious of that.
Direct influence makes sense
only with very young writers
who in the course of
figuring out how
to write first try copying the
styles and attitudes and methods
of their favorite authors.
I personally was very influenced
at the age of 21 by C.S. Lewis,
Isaac Asimov, Louise Fitzhugh,
Harriet the Spy, Herbert Marcuse,
P.G. Wodehouse, the Dialectic of
Enlightenment by Max Horkheimer
and Theodor Adorno, and my
then fiancee to name a few.
For a while in my early
20s, I put a lot of effort
into copying the sentence rhythms
and comic dialogue of Don DeLillo.
I was also very taken
with the strenuously vivid
and all-knowing prose of Robert
Coover and Thomas Pynchon.
And the plots of my first two
novels were substantially borrowed
from two movies, The American Friend
by Wim Wenders and Cutter's Way
by Ivan Passer, basically stole two
plots whole cloth from those movies.
But to me, these various influences
seem not much more meaningful
than the fact that when I was 15
my favorite music group was the
Moody Blues.
A writer has to start
somewhere but where exactly he
or she starts is almost random.
It would be somewhat
more meaningful to say
that I was influenced
by Franz Kafka.
By this I mean, it
was Kafka as taught
by the best literature professor
I ever had who opened my eyes
to the greatness of what literature
can do and who maybe want to try
to create some literature myself.
Kafka is wonderfully ambiguous
rendering of the protagonist
of The Trial Josef K.
who is once a sympathetic
and unjustly persecuted every
man and a self-pitying criminal
who is willfully blind
to his own guilt,
was my portal to the possibilities
of fiction as a vehicle
of self-investigation as a method
of engagement with the difficulties
and paradoxes of my own life.
Kafka teaches us how
to love ourselves even
as we're being mercilessly hard
on ourselves, how to remain humane
in the face of the most
awful truths about ourselves.
It's not enough to love your
characters and it's not enough
to be hard on your characters.
You always have to be trying
to do both at the same time.
A literature in which the
good are good and are rewarded
for their goodness is a
literature of fantasy.
It's the province of
the genre novel.
A literature that treats
characters as objects within systems
of language and other formalisms
is a literature of diversion.
It's the province of the art novel.
The books that dwell between these
two extremes and recognize people
as they really are, the books whose
characters are once sympathetic
subject and dubious objects are
the ones capable of reaching
across cultures and generations
of forming collectively what
I would call literature.
The bigger problem with the
question about influences, however,
is that it seems to presuppose that
young writers are lumps of soft clay
on which certain great writers
that are living have
indelibly left their mark.
>> And what maddens
the writer trying
to answer the question honestly is
that almost everything a writer has
ever read leaves some kind of mark.
To list every writer I've learned
something from would take me hours
and it would still not answer the
question of why some books matter
to me so much more than other books.
Why even now, when I'm working I
often think about war and peace
and The Great Gatsby and never think
about Ulysses and To the Lighthouse.
How did it happen that I did
not learn anything from Joyce
or Woolf even though they
are both very strong writers?
I think the common understanding of
influences whether Harald Bloomian
or more conventional is far
too linear and one dimensional.
Art history with its progressive
narrative of influences handed
down from generation to generation
is a useful pedagogical tool
for organizing information,
but it has very little to do
with the actual experience
of being a fiction writer.
When I write, I don't feel
like a craftsman influenced
by earlier craftsmen who
were themselves influenced
by earlier craftsmen.
I feel like a member of a
single large virtual community
in which I have dynamic
relationships with other members
of the community, most of
whom are no longer living.
As in any other community, I have
my friends and I have my enemies.
I find my way to those corners of
the community where I feel most
at home, most securely but also
provocatively among my friends.
Once I've read enough books to have
identified who they are and this is
where the young writer's process
of active selection comes in,
the process of choosing
whom to be influenced by.
I worked to advance
our common interests.
By means of what I write and how
I write, I fight for my friends
and I fight against my enemies.
I want more readers to
appreciate the literally values,
the glory of 19th century
Russian fiction.
I couldn't care less whether
readers love James Joyce
and my work represents
an active campaign
against the values I dislike:
sentimentally, weak narrative,
overwrite prose, solipsism,
self-indulgence, misogyny
and other parochialisms, sterile
game playing, overt didacticism,
moral simplicity, unnecessary
difficulty,
informational fetishes, and so on.
Indeed much of what might be called
actual influence is negative.
I don't wanna be like this
writer or that writer.
The situation is never
static of course.
Reading and writing fiction is a
form of active social engagement,
of conversation, and competition.
It's a way of being and becoming.
Somehow at the right moment when
I'm feeling particularly lost
and forlorn there's always
a new friend to be made,
an old friend to distance myself
from, an old enemy to be forgiven,
a new enemy to be identified.
Indeed and I'll say more about
this later or perhaps not.
It's impossible for me-- it's im--
I don't know what I'm
about to refer to.
It's coming later in the sentence.
Indeed it's impossible for
me to write a new novel
without first finding
new friends and enemies.
With strong motion, my new
friends were Dostoevsky
and Flannery O'Connor.
My new enemies were the
academic postmoderns.
To start writing The Corrections, I
befriended Kenzaburo Oe, Paula Fox,
Halldor Laxness, and Jane Smiley
who I just shook hands with.
With my new novel,
I found new allies
in Stendhal, Tolstoy
and Alice Munro.
For a while, Philip Roth was
my new bitter enemy but lately,
unexpectedly he's become
a friend as well.
I still campaign against
American pastoral
but the fearless dionysiac
ferocity of Sabbath's Theater
when I finally read it this
last year became an inspiration.
It's been a long time since I felt
as grateful to a writer as I did
when reading the scene
in Sabbath's Theater
when Mickey Sabbath's
best friend catches him
in the bathtub holding a picture
of the friend's adolescent daughter
in a pair of her underpants,
where the scene
in which Sabbath finds a
paper coffee cup in the pocket
of his army jacket and
decides to abase himself
by begging for money in the subway.
Roth may not wanna have me or any
other living writer as a friend,
but I was happy at these moments
to claim him as one of mine.
I'm happy to hold up the savage
hilarity of Sabbath's Theater
as a correction and reproach
of the sentimentality
of certain young American writers
and critics who seem to believe
in defiance of Kafka that
literature is about being nice.
The second perennial question
is what time of day do you work
and what do you write on.
This must seem to the people
who ask it like the safest
and politest of questions.
I suspect it's the question people
ask a writer when they can't think
of anything else to
ask and yet, to me,
it's the most disturbingly
personal and invasive of questions.
It forces me to picture
myself sitting
down at my computer every
morning at 8 o'clock
to see objectively the person who
as he sits down in this computer
in the morning wants only to be
a pure invisible subjectivity.
When I'm working, I
don't want anybody else
in the room including myself.
Question number three is, I read an
interview with an author who says
that at a certain point in writing
a novel, the characters take over
and tell them what to do.
Does this happen to you too?
This question always
raises my blood pressure.
Nobody ever answered it
better than Nabokov did
in his Paris Review interview
where he fingered E.M. Forster
as the source of the myth about a
novelist's characters taking over
and claimed that unlike Forster
who let his characters sail away
on their passage to India.
He himself worked his
characters "like galley slaves."
When a writer makes a
claim like Forster's,
the best case scenario
is that he's mistaken.
More often unfortunately, I get
the sense of a writer who seems
to be trying to aggrandize himself,
trying to distance his own work
from the mechanistic
plotting of genre novels.
The writer wants us to believe that
unlike those hacks who can tell you
in advance how their
books are gonna end.
His imagination is so powerful and
his character is so real and vivid
that he has no control over them.
The best case here again
is that it isn't true
because the notion presupposes
a loss of authorial will
and abdication of intent.
The novelist's primary
responsibility is to create meaning
and if you could somehow leave
this job to your characters,
you would necessarily be
avoiding it yourself and,
of course, it can never be avoided.
But let's assume for charity's
sake that the writer who claims
to be the servant of his
characters isn't simply trying
to flatter himself.
What might he actually mean?
He probably means that once
a character has been fleshed
out enough to begin to
form a coherent whole,
a kind of inevitability
is set in motion.
He means specifically that the
story he originally imagine
for a character often turns out
not to follow from the liniments
of the character he's
been able to create.
I may abstractly imagine a character
who might intend to make a murderer
of his girlfriend and his
children, but then discover
in the actual writing that the
character I'm actually able
to make work on the page
has reserves of compassion
or self-awareness that renders such
an outcome unlikely or impossible.
The key phrase here
is work on the page.
Everything under the sun is
imaginable and proposable
in the abstract, but the writer
is always limited by what he
or she is actually able to
make work, to make plausible,
to make sympathetic, to make
entertaining, to make compelling,
and above all, to make
distinctive and original.
As Flannery O'Connor famously said,
"A fiction writer does
whatever she can get away with
and nobody ever got away with much."
Once you actually start writing
the book as opposed to planning
that the universe of conceivable
human types and behaviors quickly
and dramatically shrinks to the
microcosm of human possibilities
that you contain within yourself.
A character dies on the page if
you can't hear his or her voice.
In a very limited sense, I
suppose, this amounts to taking over
and telling you what the
character will and won't do,
but the reason the character can't
do something is that you can't.
The task then becomes to figure out
what the character can do to try
to stretch the narrative as
far as possible to be sure not
to overlook exciting potentialities
that you wouldn't necessarily have
guessed you had inside you while
continuing to bend the narrative in
the direction of the potentiality
that best accords with
the meaning you're after.
I'll be rewriting that
sentence which brings me
to perennial question number four.
Is your fiction autobiographical?
I'm suspicious of any novelist
who would honestly answer no
to this question and yet, my
strong temptation when I'm asked
that myself is to answer no.
Of the four perennial
questions, this is the one
that always feels the most hostile.
Maybe I'm just projecting
that hostility,
but I feel as if my powers of
imagination are being challenged
as in this is a true work of fiction
or just a thinly disguised
account of your own life.
And since there are only so many
things that can happen to you
in your life, you're
surely gonna use up all
of your autobiographical
materials soon if indeed,
you haven't used it up already.
And so you probably won't be writing
anymore good books, will you?
In fact, if your books are just
thinly disguised autobiography,
maybe they weren't as interesting
as we thought they were.
Because after all,
what makes your life
so much more interesting
than anybody else's.
It's not as interesting as
Barack Obama's life, is it?
And also, for that matter, if
your work is autobiographical,
why didn't you do the honest thing
and write a nonfiction encounter.
Why dress it up in lies?
What kind of bad person are
you telling us lies to try
to make your life seem more
interesting and dramatic?
>> I hear all of these other
questions in the question
and it has the effect of making the
very word autobiographical feels
shameful to me.
My own strict understanding of
an autobiographical novel is one
in which the main character
closely resembles the author
and experiences many
of the same scenes
that the author experienced
in real life.
My impression is that
Hemingway's A Farewell to Arms,
Charlotte Bronte's Villette,
Saul Bellow's Augie March,
Christina Stead's The
Man Who Loved Children,
and Remarque's All Quiet
on the Western Front.
All of the masterpieces are
substantially autobiographical
in this regard but most
novels, interestingly, are not.
My own novels are not.
In 30 years, I don't think I've
published more than 20 or 30 pages
of scenes drawn directly from real
life scenes that I participated in.
I'd actually tried to write a
lot of more pages than that,
but these scenes rarely
seem to work in a novel.
They embarrass me or they
don't seem interesting enough,
or most frequently, they
don't seem quite relevant
to the story I'm trying to tell.
Late in The Corrections, there's
a scene in which Denise Lambert,
who resembles me to the extent of
being the youngest child in a family
of five, tries to teach
her demented father how
to do some simple stretching
exercises and then has to deal
with his having wet the bed.
That actually happened
to me and I took a number
of the details straight
from my life,
some of what Chip Lambert
experiences when he's
with his father in the
hospital also happened to me.
And I did write an entire short
memoir, The Discomfort Zone
which consists almost
entirely of scenes
that I experienced first
hand, but that was nonfiction.
And so I ought to be able to answer
the perennial autobiography question
with the resounding unashamed
no or at least to answer
as my friend Elizabeth
Robinson does.
"Yes, 17 percent, next question."
The problem is that
in another sense,
my fiction is extremely
autobiographical and moreover
that I consider my job as a
writer to make it ever more so.
My conception of a novel is that
it ought to be a personal struggle,
a direct and total engagement
with the author's story
of his or her own life.
This conception again
I take from Kafka
who although he was never
transformed into an insect
and although he never
had a piece of food,
an apple from his family's
table lodged in his flesh
and rotting there, devoted
his whole life as a writer
to describing his personal struggle
with his family, with women,
with moral law, with his
unconscious, with his sense
of guilt, and with the modern world.
Kafka's work which grows out
of the nighttime dream world
in Kafka's brain is
more autobiographical
than any realistic retelling at his
daytime experiences at the office
or with his family, or with
a prostitute could have been.
What is fiction after all if not
a kind of purposeful dreaming?
The writer works to create a dream
that is vivid and has meaning
so that the reader can then vividly
dream it and experience meaning.
And work like Kafka's
which proceeds directly
from dream is therefore
an exceptionally pure form
of autobiography.
There's a very important paradox
here that I'd like to stress.
The greater the autobiographical
content of a fiction writer's work,
the smaller its superficial
resemblance
to the writer's actual life.
The deeper the writer
digs for meaning,
the more the random particulars
of the writer's life become
impediments to deliberate dreaming.
And this is why writing good
fiction is almost never easy.
The point at which fiction seems
to become easy for a writer
and I'll let everyone
supply their own examples
of this is usually the point
at which it's no longer
necessary to read that writer.
There's a truism at least
in the United States
that every person has
one novel in them.
In other words, one
autobiographical novel.
For people who write more than one,
the truism can probably be amended
to say every person has one
easy to write novel in them,
one ready made meaningful narrative.
I'm obviously not talking here
about writers of entertainments,
not P.G. Wodehouse or John
le Carre, or Elmore Leonard,
the pleasure whose
books is not diminished
by their similarity to one another.
We read them indeed for the reliable
comforts of their familiar worlds.
I'm talking about more literary
work and it's a prejudice of mine
that literature cannot
be a mere performance.
That unless the writer is personally
at risk, unless the book has been,
in some way, for the writer,
an adventure into the unknown,
unless the writer has set himself
or herself a personal
problem not easily solved,
unless the finished book
represents the surmounting
of some great resistance.
It's not worth reading
or for the writer,
in my opinion, worth writing.
This seems to me all the more
true in an age when there are
so many other fun and inexpensive
things a reader can do besides
picking up a novel.
As a writer nowadays, you
owe it to your readers
to set yourself the
most difficult challenge
that you have some
hope of being equal to.
With every book, you have
to dig as deep as possible
and reach as far as possible.
And if you do this and you succeed
in producing a reasonably good book,
it means that the next time you try
to write a book, you're gonna have
to dig even deeper and reach
even farther, or else, again,
it won't be worth writing.
And what this means in
practice is that you have
to become a different person
to write the next book.
The person you already are already
wrote the best book he could.
There's no way to move forward
without changing yourself.
Without, in other words, working
on the story of your own life,
which is to say your autobiography.
Thanks, I'll stop there.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> So, I don't know
how the Q&A works
but I'm happy to take questions.
Are there microphones
or are they just shouted
out over the droning
of the generator?
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
>>Oh, there are microphones.
>> Yes.
>> And the gentleman
has stepped up to one.
>> I read a review of Freedom in the
Atlantic by B.R. Myers, I believe.
And there was-- it was not a
friendly review but there was a line
in it that said basically, if you're
reading Freedom, you're missing
out on some sort of great
literature that you're missing.
And so I wanted to see your opinion
on like what is the requirement
of reading established great
literature before you can read
something that is of literary
value today, that make sense?
I hope that makes sense.
>> Well, my publishers
would sincerely hope
that you did not read-- need
to read all the classics
before buying a new book.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> So there is-- that's
an interesting question.
I think that one of the
things I learned in college,
I didn't learn much about literature
until I took a German class.
One of the things that I did
valuably learn was that sometimes
when Emily Dickinson says A, she
means the opposite of A. So that is
to say those poems
are not actually--
you can't just read
through it and say, "A."
You actually have to read
very carefully and figure
out where she is actually
saying what she means
and where she is saying the
opposite of what she means,
which is to say you learn
things like irony and ambiguity.
And those are very frightening
things for a reader, a young reader,
because especially when you're young
you want to know what the text means
and you want it and
you resent the text
if it doesn't tell you
exactly what it means.
And you also, at a young age,
want moral life to be simple.
You want it to-- you want the good
to be good and you want the bad
to be bad, and you want to be able
to sit in a good position and say,
"that's bad" and feel if
you're reading a book,
that the author is on your side.
And interestingly, interestingly,
it's almost the definition
of classic literature that it
refuses to allow the reader
to occupy that comfortable
moral position.
And it takes you into these
realms where the responsibility
for figuring out what's being--
what for taking meaning from text
is significantly the readers.
And these are very valuable skills.
They're skills that
the lead reviewer
for the New York Times has not yet
acquired in 30 years of being--
[ Laughter ]
>> But, and so I think
it's a disaster.
It would be a disaster if
people stopped learning how
to read really good books
from the past when they get
to high school and college.
Because it's almost an introduction
to a way of being a grownup rather
than having a kind of adolescent
black and white view of the world.
>> And you can't just get so much.
You get connected to the mind of
somebody who is writing 200 or 300
or 400 years ago and
it's actually very hard
to do that in any other way.
So three cheers for reading
old books but you know,
I don't think you have to read
the entire Harvard Classics series
in order to read a
contemporary book.
Yes, they're all-- everyone is
lining up with this microphone.
This is the preferred hot mic.
[ Laughter ]
>> The most common criticism
that I've read in the reviews
of Freedom is the comment--
>> I thought the reviews were good.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> But no, I'm not reading
them so this is interesting.
>> They were overwhelmingly
good and being in the middle
of the book rightfully so.
But this point I found repeated and
I think it has some merit and I'd
like you to comment on it.
And that is that Patty's [phonetic]
voice is not a unique one,
that it seems quite coincidentally
to be very similar to the voice
of the author and that
she is not obviously,
you know, Jonathan Franzen.
She is entirely different person.
And this comment was repeated most
recently in Ruth Franklin's review
in The New Republic, and
if you wanna say anything
if you have read that review.
>> I don't read these.
>> Okay. But then about that
comment there, I'd appreciate
if you'd make some
comment about that.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
>> I was not unaware that
Patty wrote awfully well
for an ex-basketball playing B
student at a large state university.
[ Laughter ]
>> With no formal training
in writing.
[ Laughter ]
>> There is-- there is a certain--
there is a convention
with first person.
That's essentially a first
person narrative in third person.
That is it's being presented
as the document of an actual--
produced by an actual--
by the character herself.
And you know, there is--
what are the chances
that a pedophile named Humbert
Humbert would happen to write
as well as Vladimir Nabokov.
[ Laughter ]
>> It's really kind of like, wow,
there are two Russian immigrates
who happened to have like the
best relationship to the page
of practically anyone
who's ever written.
And you know, you could say the
same thing about Nick Carraway.
He writes awfully well.
So to that extent, I mean I think
the measure is whether you enjoy
reading the thing and if
that's what is being seized
on as a common complaint,
I'm actually very gratified
'cause I'm not too upset
about it wherever you went.
I would be happy-- I mean,
you know, it's nice to give
for critics something to
complain about in a way.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yes. Do we have to go?
I thought it was 11:25.
11:05? The whole thing
was half an hour?
>> Yeah.
>> That's not what my schedule says.
[ Laughter ]
>> My schedule is completely
misleading.
I thought we had until 11:25.
Really, truly, somebody
else wants the stage now?
[ Laughter ]
>> So sorry, I've gotta run.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.